- So how are things at "The Voice"?
I know you miss me.
- Oh my God.
So Bad.
- [Kelly] Yeah, I know.
- You know, it's,
Camila has done a good job.
Nobody's you, Okay?
Let's just say, there's
only one Kelly Clarkson.
(audience cheers)
- Good start! (laughs)
- But,
there is one person we've found
who can talk as much as you,
and that's Camila.
(audience laughing)
- She's been on here.
I know I've met her.
Yeah. We had to edit down our interview.
There's no way you guys
could be on the same season
with each other, ever.
- It'd have to be a
different kind of show.
She's passionate.
She likes talking.
She's really into it.
I love her though, for the show.
I think it's really cool.
- Although, unlike you, she's,
when she talks she makes sense.
(audience laughing)
When you do your spiel,
you know how you do--
- No.
- Like you don't even know
you've lost track
- No, no.
by the time you end your paragraph,
your book,
- I am very prolific.
- You don't even know what
you started out saying.
(audience laughing)